alright we're doing another one on one
and today I have with me Brad and we're
bullock wearing orange who discovered me
for the day yes uh so I don't know
anything about Brad's business Brad why
don't you give us me a quick rundown
what you're doing and how it can help
okay well I didn't have a very specific
challenge you put in front of you all
right I'm a creative over the topper and
so I have multiple enterprises even
though you would encouraged put things
all together yeah under one a focused
attempt I know where you'd come from
heaven but the truth is I i'm all about
parties i own a company I invented a
castle and s wheels and we take it to
your little girl's house for her
birthday party she invites her friends
over they have a slumber party it has
televisions air conditioning chandeliers
bedding for six adult men um we just
finished building a Hogwarts tile castle
for the boys it sleeps 9 adult men and
we call it dragon castle um and then
beyond all that I also have the ultimate
tailgater which is just incredible so
here's my problem I've been out there
knocking it off for about a year and a
half I now have 60 franchisors wanting
to join in on my castle party calm they
want to operate the same castle company
across America I'm on hold because I
need that big partner so I'm hunting an
elephant how do I you know Legos chucky
cheese you know Disney there's so many
amf bowling for good I don't care who my
bigger partners but when you got 60
people wanting what you do across it Oh
from Melbourne Australia Saudi Arabia
has hit me up like how can we start
running castles here we do scooby-doo
mansions like pirate ships that sleep
six guys the whole thing rocks you'll
have to just see the pictures I can't do
it justice with words other than I will
blow your mind are you in tirana you got
anybody i'm actually in houston texas um
down by Galveston Island what got you
into this business it sounds my wife
she's our Hut Brad we're broke go build
something and I've been an architect
designer award-winning play house
designer like the little playhouses okay
that for 15 years number one seller on
ebay on the internet you can find my
website I don't need a pimp it out right
now what got me to castle was my wife
telling me were broke go build something
so I started building a new design
called storybook cottage to and its
really awesome and it's a playhouse that
turns into a shed so you can put your
lawn mower in it long story short I'm
working a full-time job and at night on
show my little flash drive i'm showing
the pictures each night oh I built this
now I did this and then it got stained
and it was finished now I'm ready to put
it on craigslist or on the corner right
and the ladies in the offices are
swooping the thing is a cottage straight
out of a Thomas Kincaid painting it's a
beautiful cottage I love it so they're
swooning one of the ladies leans back
and she goes Brad I'd love to have that
on our girls birthday party well it was
sitting on a trailer just so I could
haul it a rail and I said okay fine I'll
rent it to you she goes oh my gosh and
she got what i call the jelly Happy's
the oh my gosh you know whoa as an
architect I never get the jelly Happy's
that just doesn't happen we build a
building or a house we don't get jelly
out so I'm said that going okay this is
new and she is freaking out so I'm
listening I'm feeling the vibe and she
goes we're gonna have a slumber party
whoa time out slumber party if you're
going to do a slumber party I'll put an
air conditioner in it I'll pad the walls
with purple crush development
chandeliers and I turned it into what
I'm talking about she passes out we
revived her I was like oh my gosh her
whole family is princess princess
princess I said would you rather me
build the castle ha and we got more
jelly hobbies and that's how was two
years ago I've been running for over a
year and a half 150 plus parties under
my belt we are mass-producing very soon
as soon as i got my partner lined out we
went ahead and we were a comic comic
blues in Houston I'm getting so much
press I'm in negotiations for my own TV
show can't drop the network anything but
I was on the phone with them just now
got one season commitment so now let me
paint the picture my college of him I
have going to be on national TV on a
really cool man in sight I don't tell
say the network we can probably figure
out man kind of channel i'll be on with
a really cool show and guess what i'll
be having on every episode one of my
castles it'll be my construction office
right we're going to be freaking out I
cannot handle the growth I have 60
people wanting it and they're the ones
that know about me wait till it gets
exposed higher I'm looking for the
hunting elephant but in a quick rapid
timeframe go your turn why do you need
the partner though capital coming in is
is about fifteen percent above breakeven
I've been I've been profitable since
august of last year so well that makes
one year now well good for me run your
possibility big deal now it's a big
freakin deal you know this you've been
down the challenging road so I got
profitable last August holding it
holding it but to build the new
prototypes and to build the okay i can
take into the castle world you get an
ipad and using augmented reality i know
3d i've taught and all that at the
University you can like do a Where's
Waldo oh there's a diamond and the
little groups can find these diamonds
spinning in midair in the castle they're
freaking out we got development costs
that I keep spending the development
costs on developing like the dragon
castle we're building pirate ship and
we're building a giant Xbox the xbox is
18 feet obviously my passion dictates
that money to just keep pedaling on
building building and concept I need
that guy or that team a you know whoever
it is to say and I thought I had
something with lego but I never got
through but I need that guy it's like
okay Brad let me go and make this the
management level of business you know
the different flywheels is talked about
from good be great and all the great
business books I am definitely a creator
I am NOT the manager yeah there's no way
you're ever going to say brad is a great
manager no that's not me inventor yes oh
you can tell your passion shines through
your speaking of milling the words in a
minute it's great with the with the
franchising model yeah the whole idea
here is that the franchisees are
financing the growth they're paying you
so if you got these guys line up what's
the franchise fee if you figured out
yeah it's 15 grand and that is is where
I want to be is have that had that
happen that's really why I even open
that little Pandora's box to deliver the
units at the level i want is the
challenge i could probably get $15,000
checks if I could deliver the units in a
year or in six months there's that
hurdle of here's your castle Tulsa
Oklahoma or national Tennessee in all
the different places your boy unit your
girl unit the the development cost is
higher than I can I could get and then
qualifying people takes a little longer
than I thought it would through the
banks to get
franchises and stuff so I'm sitting here
on the edge of a national exposure which
is exciting that I'm holding back an
avalanche the best I can so it's like
the idea oh I'm 15,000 is what 900,000
you're almost at a million dollars
that's not enough for you well it's
probably realistically only half if I
get to the to the take the rose-colored
glasses off only half we get across the
finish line now having the marketed
franchises I haven't told anybody you
can have one it's they're coming to me
saying I want to do this Brad so it's
kind of like um I need to I'm more
creative than I am here fill in this
application with the bank of america or
whoever and not these teach cross these
eyes i have sat down with the genius guy
who said Brad you need to run it as a
club it's a lot cheaper to set up from
state to state franchise walls crap I
don't know or care about but I need to
know so i can grow so basically a just
like best western hotel chain that's not
a franchise that's a that's a club how
you gonna call that problem you or not
we got a digit you know again when you
start running a franchise business yeah
you're no longer running a tent there a
castle business exactly I'm the
franchise business so all it is is
management right you're not the guy to
do it who's going to do it you know I
didn't know that until recently this
monday i signed a contract to build the
ultimate tailgater it's all my genius
and none of my management and i love the
scenario i have with them and I think I
need to go and repeat that to be to jump
to the best solution I need to go and
repeat that and put that carrot in front
some other manufacturers that's what I
need to do that's what I should do you
don't need a manufacturer you need an
operating actually it's like an RV it's
a I mean this thing's a castle it sleeps
men and air conditioning so if i had a
way to supply the units i can take those
15,000 our checks that had that million
the 900,000 or even half of it i could
get that money if i knew i could get the
the level of product in their hands so i
have a manufacturing problem more so
than 60 people willing to have any money
you're handing me money and I can't get
you your castle fast enough so I need
the manufacturing side which all I got
to do is make a few phone calls and some
too
right websites and I'll have a
manufacturer say yeah we'll do it for
your breath excellent talk Kevin really
left side item in your biggest problem
now these 60 guys plus like if that's
not your strength you got to figure that
out now how you gonna manage all of
these franchisees yeah I think I think
it's um I think it's definitely gonna be
handed over somebody else you know
that's why I'm I'm open to you know
teaming up with somebody so that's I'm
already open to realizing that's not my
strength it's going to be someone else
physically I'm going to be over in my
mad lab scientist lab I mean I've
already got with another network of
Christmas special coming up which is
like Oh heartfelt stuff so I know where
my life is heading come up with cool
stuff make it profitable and let someone
else get paid really really good to make
it daily daily daily daily you know coke
hasn't changed much so somebody's daily
running it I invented the formula for
coke I know that's different than
running though so I'm okay with stepping
out I'm on the hunt for that guy or that
team member yep so do you have that
person in mind nobody comes to mind at
all no no that what happened on the the
ultimate tailgater that guy is freaking
awesome I mean blew me away and his
whole he's got like a medical lab
construction I mean he's awesome so he
stepped up and so if he catch if I have
somebody come up with the passion and
have the skills like a lot of I got a
fan-based dude I came to deliver the
castle without signing autographs I mean
I've been on a couple of TV shows so
that just feeds into this who the
castles in my yard hi mr. Castle guy and
I love it it's fun it's ego but ain't
paying like I want to get paid so um
that guy's gonna he'll present himself
and he made for himself through all this
other activity I'm involved in so I'll
find somebody I mean if they see the
they see the game of what I'm doing like
to understand like let's say that the
castle level two iphone was fun right
the iphone was a good phone it's so
stupid the iphone was stupid the first
time you saw it even you were going this
phone is dumb it gets turned on oh
there's the buttons this phone sucks too
because this is her buttons well now
we're way beyond that we went through
that learning curve together and it was
this oh I get it now I have to do that
with my product it's the same thing as
the iphone
you see this castle you're thinking it's
an inflatable or you think it's there
like where is it where's it built at so
the first thing I'm to just know I bring
it to you as wheels oh that's the first
one the second one is was it for for our
rental no it's all freaking night it's
it's a slumber party oh and now I'm
having to educate at the same time the
hook stay over here so now when the
little girls run up to the door and they
pull the door guess what happens we have
virtual party hosting for 20 hours where
else do you entertain all six of your
senses for 22 hours only when you travel
in your thing I thought there was only
five senses the sense of balance is the
most important sense the climbing the
fun you don't have a sense of balance
but across the bridge you dad so the
sense of balance to me is the most
important not sightseeing in all our
stuff so you open the door guess who's
on the on the TV across the castle the
king and he's like prince was your most
abused they couldn't all these rural
friends and for 22 hours we've got them
captivated @midnight one day you and I
do in new york city times square 321 the
big ball drops well the castle have the
castle countdown 3 2 1 confetti falls
inside the castle these cars freaking
out this party ever I get this all the
time you go to Facebook you'll see what
my fans are loving about my product so
raving fans got 0 in spades okay so now
when midnight comes the king comes back
on TV girls would you like to hear when
princess Stephanie my grandmother found
this castle in the valley of the flowers
and all these little 10 year olds are
going yeah so he starts little
Stephanie's walking over she has no
shoes Cinderella all right X and Ralph
so she's walking through the valley
there's this castle she opens it up it's
dark but lights are sparkly Disney
sparkles from the balcony so she's drawn
in that rich and she starts to go up the
stairway this oh we have a spiral
staircase in the castle for reals so the
knob actually twists in the movie it's
the same freaking castle the girls are
partying in there going oh my gosh
sekhar castle oh my gosh that's our
stairs oh my gosh that's our knob and
when she twist the knob a secret panel
opens up in the movie and all these gold
coins come down yeah she's not poor
anymore when one of the girls must say I
gotta try that they're gonna switch that
knob because what's gonna happen in the
castle that they're actually sleeping in
a secret panel opens up in microwave
popcorn packs individually flavored
powdered vanilla is my favorite right
now we're having that signature for the
castle there's a microwave up and right
there boom who parties like that nobody
I'm sorry went slow yeah you're crazy
you're game that's exactly right then we
went way out
but it was an entertaining story sorry
I'm sorry I think a solution well we
found it early we found the solution
putting my my venture capital hat on I'm
thinking this guy is great at promoting
the business he loves what he does he's
a crazy guy who do great on TV you know
you're out there you want to be building
the fan base but I would fear that
there's nobody running this ship because
guys like you need people to take care
of all the many details that happen when
you run a business like there's nobody
crossing T's and down in the ice for you
and if that's worth knucklebone that
right there virtual number Thank You Man
I'm scared for your business you got his
really good at you need how about your
wife what is she does he she's been with
me for you know 25 years hitman italy
celebrating a marriage that's been
awesome so she is very comfortable with
me being the guy that she can say look
we're broke go build something she's
been at being the initiator she doesn't
run to manage the ship and like i said
i'm not too worried about it i just made
this monday did we're talking about
thursday monday is when i got the
arrangements to build the ultimate
elevator which i don't know if you saw
those pictures or not but it's not
completely amazing and they stepped up
he's like I will build them and i will
run it here I just you keep forty
percent of it it's all mine la okay fair
I got other stuff to do so I moved on
and it's going faster than castle I mean
I'm sitting here just like that's the
arrangement that works for me I'm gonna
go find me some more factories for me to
send something to my website they're
blown away and there's phone calls
happening I only had to call to
factories and both of them picked up the
phone I went with the guy I like the
most his name's Joe freaking rocks i
love the guy so he's gonna run the ship
he's gonna get paid like it boom sorry
who's Joe what's he doing he's your
manufacturer no big company man he also
drives on McLaren oh man he's just
already so successful he can be see it
and have his factory oversee it not just
a VC without intelligence he's guiding
through the through the ocean he's a big
chunk of what I've been needing so I'm
thrilled that happened Monday and so
what's he's gonna make the castles no
he's he wants to
even he goes hey who's going to build
these uh it's gonna build your castles I
said that's another conversation another
day you don't put all your eggs in one
basket he's taking care of the ultimate
tailgater that thing is incredible so
it's it's a it's similar to Castle yes
and it came from the castle idea I go to
I know to have lunch with my 5th grader
that's like guys what's the best party
you can think of and one of them says a
giant football stadium and I said what
if we make a six-foot-tall a football
helmet and then the other end has a
14-foot football that's literally that
you know that uh what's the website they
told me it was tailgater kings.com
tailgate at Gamescom and then and i
don't have to explain it so that was
originally going to be for just birthday
parties a five-foot-tall Super Bowl
trophy with LED lights and fog drizzling
oh this is awesome John Madden all night
long same thing not princessy okay same
thing not princessy so it turned into
this tailgater where Houston Texans the
you know oh you LSU all these schools
tailgating is good I thought and all son
is taking on us life of its own in five
weeks but it's a journey that I have to
just handle with me being creative I've
already I got so much going on and work
on two different shows so it's like I
know where I'm going give up I'm not
greedy I guess that's what the biggest
thing is compared to most guys I don't
need ninety-one percent of the thing and
I don't care there's more than enough
money going around with what my ideas
are if they don't get if they don't get
across the finish line they don't get
built they don't get sold period so i
have to back off on things and say look
we're not doing the magic wands the
second verse on the iphone was better
than the first version of the iphone and
our second castle is where i want to be
yet but i had to say no we can go to
market by a viable product what's that
called the minimum iron yeah that i
reached that and we're making money so
the second version did I ain't all take
that so okay at the new I we have the
new castles the girls get magic wands
all of them 10 feet away they do this
and spy optic light to the struggle
though are you kidding me they're gonna
be doing that all night mon then
princess stéphanie comes up girls let's
make the castle wish and she's on a TV
outside the castle raise it high twirl
it above your head and click your heels
and then whenever there one touches the
actual wall this is basically we
technology
anyway you know Xbox kinetics is easy
stuff you touch the wall guess what
happens he goes into full on Castle
karaoke the whole thing goes and also
baby baby baby oh and you got Castle
karaoke for the next hour $99 upgrade on
Castle control which is an iPad all
bedazzled up that we gave mommy before
we left we can make over eleven hundred
dollars in sales after we've pulled away
they got in for four hundred dollars for
the party and oh we develop in this
castle thing that's your vibe have you
ever gone the story got a little block
of cheese that's good in the end up
buying the whole thing talk samples we
sample out everything you don't like the
virtual story you don't pay for it you
ever been out photobooth you push the
button or little photo comes out well we
got photo booths all over for ninety
nine dollars you can unlock you can
print to your heart's content up in the
balcony in front of mirror mirror on the
wall you know Mary Marilyn wall and from
the steroid nipples bugs everywhere
they'll print one help wrote one it's a
sample to cheese mommy mommy one more
pictures okay and if you're in the
moment and that's the vibe of your party
mommy we already got your visa card BAM
that's just what I'm already on my third
parties with people you want to talk
about confidence in my product people
are called me up in booking their second
and third parties for their older kids
that's great I'm just I'm really hanging
on to a rocket I know I can't do it all
I am going to try well your problem is
not getting the castles and not
manufacturing you need someone to run it
so who's the guy are you gonna find them
it's not easy you can't just say hey I'm
gonna go find a partner it is not easy
it's called hunting an elephant in my
mind and I think the easiest thing to do
is find another Joe find another
elephant who wants to do this and I
don't want it to be an individual with
the factory I really rather be something
who gets the clout for example if it was
a pixar disney slam dunk could you
imagine being in Rapunzel's actual tower
in your freaking yard my friend up in
Oklahoma big money and stuff like that
he's like Brad you're bringing amusement
parks to people's houses that will never
spend four grand on a family trip to
distant but they'll drop a thousand
bucks on you over the next four years so
you're in the same playing ground I was
like yeah I've never thought of it that
way and this is business guys talking to
me after the initial the info dump I'm
doing on you about what I do now then I
start getting to some really good stuff
that's why episode to episode 3 maybe
even better because we get to so Brad
how did you do what you do hey Evan this
is where we're
at um so he is he's got a lot of insight
and he's like you really need managers
and he's like actually on a hunt for me
but we need somebody who gets the value
I mean even chuck e cheese I mean I mean
there's so many people Legos would be
perfect I have people asked me could you
please build a Lego castle or a Gotham
City where it looks like a city coming
down the street and you go in and set a
bat cave and of course it's got all the
interactive to be method yeah it's got
all that stuff who would benefit best
Marvel right so I can go up and it's
really easy for me to get comp no
permission hey I need to borrow
scooby-doo yeah we'll give you a revenue
split we don't want exclusive those are
the two magic words and getting
licensing deal don't ask for an
exclusive and then just do a revenue
split and you get you can get everything
except this Harry Potter guy I can't get
a phone call through tool so all right
big deal know there's other castles out
there so I know how to get the licensing
deals I think I really want the big
partner to manage it with the
bureaucracies and the 18 levels and you
can't move the ship in a day not like
the nimble entrepreneurs that you coach
and work with I have to leave that
behind because I'm no longer there I'm
no longer the guy who can manage it but
guess what I've got two or three other
ideas already in the works so you know
that's just I'm going to keep going
forward somebody will present themselves
I'll say you're the guy Dean worthy
let's go next what kind of was finish
what it's kind of like a king is deemed
worthy you know like a keener I just
watched the princess movie again I I do
a lot of princess movies it's my
business so my two worries for you and
trying to figure this out is one is this
business it's chuck e cheese whatever
what you're proposing is way outside
what they do yes right so having a
marketing partnership is different than
them running your business you're saying
here's a whole new business that you can
get into and I'll be the creative spark
but you got to run it that's not an
attractive proposition to a big company
there he has a line of business and has
probably no interest in getting into it
then I will waste any time at all there
because that's a waste of time if if
chuck e cheese is all waste of time or
Disney for that matter is what interest
is Disney had
in running right now princess laramie I
just shared with you princess Stephanie
on your seventh on your daughter seventh
birthday she spent 22 sat solid hours
with princess Stephanie now you know
what kind of emotional bonding that has
happened between princess Stephanie and
your daughters and her five best friends
when they go to toys r us understanding
they're saying oh I want a Disney or I
want to Barbie from may tell no I was
living with princess Stephanie for 22
hours in my own driveway I will buy her
princess shoes I will buy her dvds I
don't buy everything from princess
Stephanie because she came to my house
that's why Disney would want it it's not
their business though they would partner
with you you know they would they would
give you marketing support potentially
but they don't want to run that business
why would definitely run a door-to-door
Castle company they don't right now no
and you're talking about asking somebody
about the iphone before they knew what
the buttons were doing okay oh I'm not
going to call I'm not gonna find anybody
on the planet Evan that says you know
I've been waiting to run a company made
with castles that guy doesn't even live
anywhere on this earth so I know not to
hunt for that guy that's not the profile
of the elephant I'm honey when I found
Joe is the first time in my life that
somebody's like dang I've got all these
resources I'm already retired I'm race
all the time with you know scca racing I
have a great time with me and my son
we're freaking rich I Drive a McLaren I
have my own private plane but this looks
like a party let me take over and build
it to the level of range rover let me
you know let me do all of it and you're
only gonna get forty percent okay I'm
down with that okay cool yeah that's a
great deal and that's not me it's not
gonna be a big company if you keep
building up your profile those
opportunities will come to you like this
guy found you because of the stuff that
you're already doing right yeah that the
TV stuffs gonna be exponential it's
going to be rocket fuel and the the
bigger position of strength that you
have the easier is going to be to make a
deal on the less you're gonna get killed
on your valuation true true I would say
your next best step is to get somebody
to help you manage your business not a
big partner just somebody who has good
detail aren't good skills that you can
go and line things up with these TV
deals and the franchise's and then
care of it they'll go into a company if
it's you know Disney or whoever yeah he
I'm I'm international okay I have a
hundred stores and locations around the
world with these many customers and I
want to help promote your brand I still
don't see them wanting to take over and
run your business you're not asleep
brand it's it's know how would they do
but a marketing partnership or somebody
who might be interested in acquiring you
you know who wants to continue to grow
that like this Joe guy yeah that's
probably a better fit no big brands
could be good partners for you right
it's a lot deal to say hey you know
princess stéphanie right I'll promote it
yeah great PR so should you have the TV
show and you you tell a good story and
you get people excited and I think my
initials are BS your what my initials
their BS oh well there you go I'm EC and
I think it means anything i have to look
that up will you need to be out there
being crazy yeah it works right you're
crazy guy you got to be on video you got
to be talking to people that's your best
skill not not figuring out contracts and
all that boring stuff that I don't you
want to know about I'm a rah-rah guy I'm
a cheerleader I'm a Pied Piper I got
fans just when I do my thing that I
literally have lawn chairs out in like
when I'm working on a project yeah it's
been that way for years this isn't
nothing new that's just how I am I
finally had lightning strike with this
castle real thing so you know we're new
territory for me it's a growth of
anything and you know some people are
still a concept idea and then I'm past
prototyping and past productivity now
I'm into a new stage and it's it's
awkward it's spooky you know I don't
want to get reamed battle and give
everything away I don't think I need to
but you know having a sounding board
with the with an orange shirt is a great
idea the great opportunity I mean I know
picking your brains not a bad one then
you're bringing your very best ideas to
me and I appreciate that because your
success obviously speaks for yourself
and you know you may or may not be able
to put some of this away pick up the
phone in the middle of the night and say
Brad okay have you thought of this okay
bye shoot me an email hit me attacks
whatever you have access to me and
um you know I don't think this is a
short-term thing I think you know I'll
be a chatting you know going forward I
mean we're both fairly young guys and
there's a lot to do um I'm excited about
it I don't have the clear direction but
I know I got to find it I gotta find a
management yeah you need the team you
know if either lip our venture
capitalist looking at your business and
you come to me see I need five million
bucks or whatever you know box to grow
your business yeah I'd say I love this
guy he's great but I would back him
because I feel great that as you grew
the whole thing would fall apart right
and wrong because you're not using your
skills as they should be used hmm yeah
you need to get that person yeah I guess
I do they don't have to be out there
marketing for you they just need to be
able to manage everything you bring in
right right then all this stuff it's
great and that's that's all you should
be doing yeah yeah I got to take a
little time out and see what i can find
as far as a good person I've got I've
got little I've got some people covering
some things for me in a way I never had
before um but hopefully uh you know this
Monday went really well in the next 72
hours things have been going crazy so
like tonight I'm chatting skyping with a
major network about a different project
somebody will present themselves and
it'll come together I mean I've been
doing it for two years now and the
momentum is such that I'm scared of the
momentum actually 60 people TV shows
cool profit raving fans all the
ingredients that key person to say a
bread let me handle your day-to-day let
me give me your cell phone you know that
kind of a person almost a personal
assistant and yes in the smallest wit
and the smallest level yes going to be
extremely helpful so that'll be what I'm
working on that's where I'm heading
don't just jump into a partnership go
yeah this is this is not your road show
or whatever your tailgating thing this
is this is this could be huge yeah this
is like getting married you know you
don't want to just give this off to
somebody give them forty percent or
sixty percent of your business right
right the reason why I brought up your
wife is often crazy guys like you are
married to people who aren't as crazy
your ears on it is in the family some
got to manage everything and she does
and she does she manages everything so
she has the skill sets potentially to
help you with what you need for your
business now working with family has its
own set of issues okay we run a lot of
rental properties like together she runs
when she tells me to go and you know
this guy didn't pay rent whatever yeah
there's she she would be awesome at it I
don't think she wants to it's a season
of life thing she's ready to Brad get it
to level two I don't have to work you
know that sort of thing and I move down
for that that doesn't I mean I'm not not
upset by that all of a they got
motivates me you know what if just on
the lawn guy attention I may be way off
what if you had a short term plan you
know it's so if this is something short
term for you you want to build the size
where you can get acquired sell it off
and you know you need that help when she
join you for that little bit and say hey
yes like that would be years that what
possible she'd probably do that and we
both want to gather this and we both
want to go retire to whatever I think
it's gonna do something though you're
not the kind of guy who's just gonna sit
on the beach oh my gosh no yes no you
already can tell um though I won't even
go into where my I'm living in my head
so yeah I think she would probably be up
for it um we'll see we'll see how
presented to her you know even if it's
just until the point where you find
another manager to help you right
because obviously you trust her like how
many years 25 years you said being
married and she has a skill set and that
that's what's holding you back like yeah
do these distributors with these
franchisees now right you'll need to
partner you have to figure out the model
and talk to a good franchise lawyer
about it too but yeah like it's gonna
start crumbling under you you can you
cancel that not yours actually feel that
I actually can't I told my producer
today I said just so you know you know
our one year thing is click and I've got
four other networks have hit me up he's
like are you kidding me I said yeah
because of monday i'll put another
website out there with this amazing
thing we're building it and it's going
to go into all these football games
after that you can't contain something
like this i lo it unique not to break my
own backpack my back but who else has a
castle with wheels I mean seriously it's
the only one on the planet
oh that gets attention eventually I've
been out there for two years now now
it's on blogs and it's yeah facebook
google+ and it's out there it's going to
crumble under me and if that happens wow
what a ride it was but I don't think it
will I'm not I'm not danger of that
happening so you don't only have a
unique product you've got you your
unique thanks man you your unique you're
very sellable and and congrats for
actually understanding your weaknesses
because I was probably the biggest
problem I had when financing companies
is the CEO the founder is so crazy
attached to everything that you're doing
and as I'm willing to bring people on to
help them yeah right so if it's your
wife or somebody I was thinking about
professional management to support all
the stuff that you suck at so you can
focus on what you're amazing that is
really expect that just made me think of
something that would be great at it I
just that is awesome yeah I think I can
hit another guy up on it yeah and you
know what with anything unless it's your
wife if with anybody else still start
small you know don't just give them
forty percent of the business or
whatever it is because it's gotta be you
will work well with long-term right like
you don't want this business to be
running to the ground and partnerships
done well are awesome just like a
marriage but but when they're not done
well man you're warm hey yeah you hear
the people start small right like even
even a salary to start say here here's
what you're gonna do you have a way to
earn in if we start making some money
you report the pay somebody right now to
manage his business I meant that that
point where I probably could um like are
you taking a salary you said your break
even with that includes you well I take
the prop then I push the company more
ads and more papers more sparkles and
tiaras and I'm always taking it and just
pushing the company i think if i had to
mindset then i'm going to push the
company by offloading some of this to
spending that on a salary i think all
things would go better the attention
that the new Dragon castle got at Comic
Blues I mean we made the news again
magazines again that thing is huge and
that one going into play takes me
completely I can't manage it doubling
the size of my units the number of units
i have really eliminates me as a
manager by default you know he just
there's no more time in a day so the
role yet you're playing right now is way
harder to find than a professional
manager oh yeah they get something to
come in and say here's the deal go make
it happen and you know take care of all
the operations that's a skill that's
pretty commonly available yeah what
we'll have is unique out there making
deals being the crazy guy getting TV
shows all that stuff that is so unique
and you got to focus on that we've been
casting an opposite of me for about
three months the network's already done
at once first season's commitment but
they want somebody to cut the camera off
of my craziness right and cut to
somebody else he's like oh my gosh we're
going to do that or yeah let's do that
either way right because I'm like pure
vanilla out of the bottle straight
extract you gotta go down a little
something and so they've been casting
for three months and they told me the
tennis before I went on this with you
that ok Brad were going with Alex he's
the guy we're editing it up and you know
we'll see what happens next week I'm
like okay cool so yeah i understand i'm
very unique they told me the network he
said ok Brad we realize we're not gonna
find another you nail yeah yeah you're
not gonna find another me I've never met
another me except for Joe Joe's someone
yeah man Evan I yeah another knuckle
bump this is awesome I got some action
steps out of this and you spurred me
where most of my friends win it because
you know I got a lot of raw raw people
around me like yo Brad go and you know
you're actually I can see your wheels
are turning what's brads next step yeah
I want to follow this guy I can see
where you're at I mean your words and
your body language is it's good and I
appreciate it and I will try to position
it to wear a what-do-you-call-it buyout
firms get excited yeah like ooh now it's
that all the pieces the puzzle we like
we're missing a big piece so we'll go
get it then luck man I'm excited it was
it was definitely a memorable experience
meeting you yeah and same here and I
know it's not the last time so hey good
luck with all of this activity I'm
rooting for you man you're gonna do
great so now keeping posters what's
happened if you have any questions in
the future let me know will do virgin
too hey there we go I'll see you on
version 2 then hey I gotta go
hi Evan thanks Brad cheers you bet